[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
July 19th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
Americans hourly pay Rose four percent
in June compared to a year ago and that
puts wage growth ahead of inflation for
the first time in two years
wsj economics reporter Amira amokwe
joins us so Amara this is definitely
good news for people's wallets what's
been their experience since inflation
took off a few years ago so Americans
have been experiencing higher prices for
their everyday items we really saw steep
increases for those common things that
we use every day and that we need every
day whether that be groceries gas rent
and that basically meant that Americans
purchasing power declined and relative
to what inflation was doing we didn't
see the increase in wage gains keep up
over the last two years but how does
current wage growth compared to before
inflation took off you know before the
pandemic one of the economists I spoke
to for my story points it out that yes
although we now have wages outpacing
inflation for the first time in two
years really when we look at what the
trend was pre-pandemic real wages that
is inflation-adjusted wages are below
that Trend so although people's pay
checks are better keeping up with
inflation right now they're still not
where they would have been had the
pre-pandemic trend continued what are
the current wage gains tell us about the
state of the labor market so really the
labor market is on quite solid footing
and it's actually a lot stronger than
many economists had expected then the
Federal Reserve had expected and that is
actually creating complications for the
Federal Reserve because the FED is on
this campaign to lower inflation they've
been raising interest rates since last
year in an effort to cool the economy to
pump the brakes on the economy a little
bit and nobody really expected the labor
market to be as strong as it has
continued to be in June we saw over 200
000 jobs added we see unemployment at a
still very low rate and we also see
quite robust wage gains what it says is
that the labor market is still strong
it's still tight when we think about the
number of available workers compared
with the number of job openings you know
job openings are still like C the number
of available workers so in a lot of ways
we're seeing that employers are still
looking for workers or holding on to the
ones they have so a very solid labor
market still and we've seen inflation
come down from near 10 percent down to
three percent although it's come down in
the past year significantly prices are
still Rising right yes and that's a very
important point to note although
inflation has cooled we are still seeing
higher prices for a lot of items and
when you think about where we've come
from although workers wages are now
outpacing inflation workers have really
had to digest these higher prices over
these last two years and so you know
it's not necessarily A Cause to be
overly optimistic or overly exuberant it
is good that people are feeling better
but you also have to remember that
people have really been dealing with
higher prices for a while now and we
still are seeing prices go up just at a
slower pace and also there are some
items for which prices are still going
up so the cool down in inflation hasn't
been even across the board
do economists feel that this wages
versus inflation trend is likely to
continue so when I asked economists
about what to expect going forward what
I essentially heard was that as
inflation comes down we should see the
increase in wage gains also slow down
because inflation has been rising and
because the labor market has been tight
workers have been saying to their
employers who compensate me accordingly
right pay me more because the things
that I need to buy are more expensive
and they can also make those demands
because they know that employers have
been scrambling to attract workers and
retain workers so basically as we see
inflation slow down as it has been the
economists expect that we'll also see
wage growth slow down and we actually
have been seeing that so wage gains have
slowed down from where they were earlier
in the year
but it is still more money in people's
pockets how is that affecting Economist
projections about the possibility of the
economy heading toward a recession right
so the wage gains put the FED in a more
difficult position right a Fed chair
Jerome Powell has said for instance we
really do like to see people making more
money particularly lower income people
we like to see those wage needs at the
same time if people have more money in
their pockets or if they feel like
they're doing better relative to
inflation that could encourage them to
continue spending that could encourage
them to continue making purchases and
that could then make it harder for the
FED to bring down inflation and so it
just kind of complicates what the FED is
trying to do here which is they're
trying to slow the economy but not slow
it's so much that we have a painful
recession and so as wage growth
continues to be solid it then makes the
FED say hmm are we doing enough have we
raised interest rates enough to the
point where we're going to get the
outcome that we want that's Wall Street
Journal economics reporter Amir and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]